apex Legends season four assimilation
has arrived bringing a new legend weapon
battle past map changes and more here's
everything you need to know to
assimilate yourself into the new season
let's talk about revenant first the Robo
killer has joined the apex games and
he's bringing a literally deadly
combination of abilities to the
competition revenant is an assassin and
his abilities reflect that his passive
called stalker lets him Crouch walk
faster and climb walls higher than other
characters his tactical is called
silence and it's a throne device that
damages the enemy and temporarily
disables their own abilities
finally there's his ultimate death totem
this keeps your teammates alive for a
limited time if they die they'll simply
respawn at the totem ready for more
action
revenant isn't unkillable however his
low profile trait means that he takes an
extra 5% damage if you're not able to
pick revenant for your squad right away
don't worry you should still be able to
find the new weapon The Sentinel this
sniper rifle has a unique mechanic
compared to others in the game you can
switch your fire to an energized state
while powered on the Sentinel fires
special projectiles that deal extra
damage to shields these projectiles
leave trails and make a unique sound so
other players will know the Sentinel has
been powered up to activate this
energized state you'll need to give up
one shield battery in your inventory and
the effect will only last for 90 seconds
along with a new sniper comes sniper
ammo up until this point
snipers SMGs and LMGs all use the same
ammo but respawn is changing that now
you'll find unique sniper ammo for the
longbow triple take charge rifle and a
new Sentinel note that the g7 is missing
from this list it's now an assault rifle
instead of course you can also deck out
the Sentinel and other weapons with new
battle pass rewards as usual the
assimilation battle Pass includes 100
levels of rewards to unlock but you'll
get some bonuses just for picking it up
buying the pass gets you epic skins for
Pathfinder lifeline and crypto plus a
legendary skin for the r99
the Battle Pass will cost you nine
hundred and fifty apex coins but you can
also grab a bundle for twenty eight
hundred coins that automatically unlocks
the first 25 levels of rewards and Nets
you the perfect soldier skin for Wraith
if you don't want to spend money that's
cool to anyone who plays season four can
still earn five apex packs and caustics
cyber sludge skin now let's talk about
map changes world's edge is getting a
fresh coat of paint and some key spots
first up is the planet harvester which
has been dropped smack dab in the middle
of the map the harvester is a massive
structure full of close quarters
hallways and corners to battle in the
harvester has also calls capital city to
split in half with one chunk to the west
one to the east with a volcanic fissure
between good news if you fall into the
pit you won't immediately die bad news
you will take 25 damage every time you
fall in and the warm wind will carry you
to safety very very slowly making you a
pretty open target lastly there's an
all-new spot called the survey camp if
you check it out you'll actually find
racks of weapons inside some of the
buildings if all of this has you itching
to jump back into ranked mode then
there's one more thing you need to know
much like capital city it's being split
in two this season from now through
March 23rd you'll be battling and
ranking up on world's edge for March
24th through May 5th you'll move to
Kings Canyon and start ranking up from
scratch to different rank series means
two sets of rewards plus bonus animated
badges for top players on both Maps
season 4 comes alongside a new update
bringing weapon balance changes and
quality of life improvements on top of
everything we talked about here so be
sure to check out the full patch notes
on gamespot stay tuned for our upcoming
revenant legend guide and tons more
assimilation coverage we'll see you in
the apex games
[Music]